Any remedy for birding mouth symptoms? This was a question that came in last week on the chat as well.
Birding mouth symptoms and birding mouth syndrome. Again, you would be right in line. It's
most likely an autoimmune condition. It can be from an issue with chronic lands. It can be from
food deficiencies. You've got to dig into it. We need to hold this with everybody, but you've got to find
a practitioner. You contact us at schedule a case where you would be or find a local practitioner if
you're more packed to feel comfort with that and have somebody that will dig to find causes.
Most of the time, people get frustrated because they go into their GP and they have a symptom
like the questions you guys are asking. Then maybe they'll run a CVC at a complete metabolic
panel and within most of them are within normal lab ranges and they say, we know what's wrong with
you called a psychologist. It's very important. That's why you're seeking alternative care.
You need to find a functional medicine doctor that doesn't do something similar. It's not just,
oh, we're going to throw this supplement at it or this supplement at it, but they're going to dig to find
some causes. That's through going through kind of what we're talking about on these calls,
a pattern of understanding differential diagnosis. You're going, well, what could it be?
So you're thinking, oh, you've got to find a practitioner that once is willing to put on a Sherlock
Holmes hat, go, well, what could this be? I already know syndrome, but it'd be a prodigal
issue. Sure, it could be. This person have something as simple as a sensitivity to something they're
putting in their mouth like toothpaste or something. Could they have a sensitivity to the mercury that's
in their fillings? Could they have a sensitivity to, there's just a plethora of different things that
you want to test for. So digging to that cause, there's, again, bottom line, there's always a cause
and you have to dig to find out what that causes.